put you on the spot when a lot of the
world hears Yale they think privilege
they think elite they think it has so
much more resources visa V any other
entity why invest in this well it's an
interesting question and I think that it
I'm going to answer it with my actual
fundraising hat on because I also do
some some fundraising for you as a
member of the class of 82 what I tell
people when I have to go out as a class
agent and ask them to give is Yale is
doing a tremendous amount in the world
that I don't think people realize it's
not just the impact of students like you
will go off in the world and do amazing
things it's incredible what the students
of today are doing in their own
community and globally it's not just
what you will do with your intellect
when you go on to your job in whatever
sector you you have it in the future it
it's it's not just the knowledge that
comes out of New Haven they're doing
projects all over the world there's
scientific projects you know finding
that fern in Africa that's going to be
the next wonder drug you know we're
doing nursing projects in China we're
teaching helping to teach the Chinese
universities about a liberal arts
education which is going to have ripple
effects for education of people in that
part of the world there is so much that
Yale is doing and yell is a rich
institution but it's what it's doing
with that is it's being a not just a
thought leader but having an actual
impact in the world that I don't think
people really think about and I think
that's worth supporting beyond its and
again people say well you know I'm just
supporting kids to come to school in New
Haven it's only 5,000 of them are you
know 10,000 recount the graduate school
that's not what it's about it's got it's
a catalyst for a lot of other really
important things in the world I think
Stephen so you mentioned impact and I
find that attempting to maximize impact
is a
a large draw for me and trying to decide
what to do with my present or future
time talent and treasure do you think
that such photometric is appropriate in
some all or no circumstances I think
it's right I think it's hard to measure
sometimes but I think it's very
appropriate you know when you talk about
how do you measure the impact of dollars
it's it's somebody's here to do you know
if I if is a fundraiser do XY and z I
will get you know a B and C dollars when
you try to measure the impact of human
capital which is what we're talking
about it's difficult but I think it's
really important partly because if we
think that the donation of time and
talent is important then it would be
good to be able to measure it to show
the impact it's something we struggle
with metrics is something we struggle
with at the AOA because we think what we
do is important and we know that it
leads to stronger connections and many
times to giving you gauge somebody more
in any kind of organization but with
Yale and they see part of what I was
just talking about or they see how what
a fabulous place it is just locally on
campus and what kind of opportunity it's
providing for people who will go out and
make an impact in the world they are
more likely to give and that's important
too but I think it's a really good
question but it's hard to figure out how
to do it